as we mentioned earlier an American
pastor who was freed after two years of
detention in Turkey is expected to
arrive in the US later today
Andrew Brunson and North Carolina native
was flown overnight to a US military
base in Germany where he received a
medical exam and was photographed
embracing the US flag Bronson's release
came after intense pressure on the
Turkish government by the u.s. a Turkish
court had convicted him of having links
to terrorism
Errol Barnett is at the White House with
the very latest Darrell good morning
good morning well in an interview
following Andrew Brunson's release his
sister thanks president Trump and senior
Republican senators for quote working so
hard and tirelessly to bring Andrew home
now for his part president Trump says
he's looking forward to welcoming
Brunson to the Oval Office today we
secured the release of Pastor Andrew
Brunson from Turkey at a campaign star
rally in Ohio President Trump
hailed Pastor Brunson's release after
pressuring Turkey for his freedom
he went through a lot you know all about
pastor Brunson he went through a lot but
he's on his way back
in a statement Brunson said this is the
day our family has been praying for the
American evangelical preacher was
released by turkey after serving more
than two years following accusations of
spying and aiding terrorists the US
government said it saw no credible
evidence that Brunson had done anything
wrong the move follows lengthy
negotiations between Washington and
Ankara and as seen as an olive branch
offered by Turkey Brunson was detained
after a failed military coup in 2016
tens of thousands were arrested or fired
from their jobs in the crackdown that
followed Turkey has been suffering from
a financial crisis following the u.s.
doubling tariffs on steel and aluminum
back in August we spoke to Turkey and he
went through a system and we got him out
they've been trying to get him out for a
long time earlier Friday President Trump
denied the release was part of any
larger agreement at all there was no
deal but we're very happy to have him
and have him in good shape now no matter
how we got here this is seen as a
positive sign for US relations with
Turkey and a statement the chairman of
the Foreign Relations Committee that
senator bob Corker said that this move
represents an important step towards
mending US relations with Turkey Anthony
Errol Barnett at the White House thanks
Errol very happy to have him headed home
yes well the president answered that
question I had about brunson whether or
not he was impacted by what's going on
right right here in that consulate